Google Maps provides
a suite of APIs
to let developers
access location data.
Each of the APIs packages
up unique functionality.
And today, I'm going to
give you a quick tour
through all those APIs.
So let's start
with the Roads API.
Roads API provides
an important service
that can clean up any
collected GPS data produced
by your mobile application.
Say, for example, you
collect about 10 GPS points
from your app while
driving around in a car.
They are more than likely
a poor representation
of the path you drove.
Some points are
in a park, others
are in the neighboring street
By using the Roads API, you can
turn those 10 inaccurate GPS
points from this to this without
the need for a higher sample
rate, which will
increase battery drain.
The Roads API uses
Google Maps data
to ensure the
points are actually
on roads you've traversed.
Another feature of the
Roads API is speed limits.
Now, that feature's for
paying customers only,
but the value of it for,
say, speed or fastest
route estimating is immense.
So you might want
to check it out.
Imagine you're managing
a number of pizza stores.
When an order comes in, you
could use the Distance Matrix
API to find out the distance
from the customer to all
of your shops at once.
Then you can choose
the closest store
to deliver the pizza from.
When it's time to
deliver the pizza
from the shop to the customer,
you can use the Directions API.
This API allows you to pass
in addresses or lat/long
pairs as the input, and retrieve
driving, walking, cycling,
or public transport directions.
This API also supports
route optimization.
So say the driver is using
your pizza delivery app.
You can use the Directions
API to get the shortest path
between all the delivery stops.
In addition, you can give the
customers approximate arrival
time of their delicious meal,
using the API to estimate
travel time in current traffic.
Places API lets you
convert coordinates
into meaningful place names.
So next time you want to invite
your buddies to 3.14159265,
2.718281828, just
stop, and tell them
you'll meet at
O'Shea's Irish pub.
Other times, you
might have an address
but need its coordinates.
Say you're building
a house hunting app,
and you want to plot a bunch
of properties on a map.
You could use the Geocoding
API to convert addresses
to lat/longs.
Reverse geocoding is also
supported, converting lat/longs
back into addresses.
This is useful, for example,
if you're writing something
like a weather widget app.
Grabbing the GPS coordinates
from the user's phone,
you can display the
country, suburb, or street
they're currently at by passing
the data received from the API.
Other related APIs we provide
include the Elevation API
and the Timezone API.
For full details
about all web service
APIs available to
extend your app,
see the Google Maps APIs
developer docs at this link.
Each of those APIs is
really powerful on its own.
But when used together,
they bring synergy
into your app that gives
it that extra edge.
[MUSIC PLAYING]